what should we call this
all that you've done for us
I think it's something more something
darker
[Music]
I was thinking
flashpoint
hey everybody what should we call this
brave new DC movie universe that Ezra
Miller is going to whip up for us
so this is gonna be a video all about
the flashpoint movie there have been a
couple things that have changed and a
lot of that has to do with what's going
on in and around Justice League I've
gotten a whole bunch of questions now
about what's going to happen given that
they've confirmed that Batman will be a
big part of the story of flashpoint but
they're not doing the exact same comic
book storyline if you've never seen any
of my videos before we do comic book
stuff every week we got crazy stuff with
infinity war coming down the road and
star wars make sure you subscribe to get
everything there's a weekly flash ring
giveaway that's going on right now I'll
explain at the end of the video but in
order to explain what's going on with
flashpoint you have to understand
Justice League so just careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen Justice
League yet so at the end of that movie
you have the birth of the modern Justice
League - Green Lantern and a couple
other members I know everybody wants to
know
where's Martian Manhunter who knows you
know he could pop up anywhere at this
point but almost everybody is familiar
with some version of the flashpoint
story whether you read the comic book
whether you watch the animated movie
which is basically the exact same thing
is the comic book or you saw the TV show
version and you understand the concept
at least Barry goes back in time to save
his mother but in doing so just
completely screws the timeline recently
Geoff Johns has been talking about all
the stuff that's coming up because there
was a bunch of news with Shazam and the
other films so naturally the flash
flashpoint movie was a part of that
discussion he said that they have their
script they're looking for the director
but he actually talked about what the
story was going to be like some of the
elements because there are a couple big
question marks it's really expensive to
put these Justice League actors in films
so you can't just assume that they would
do the comic book story with every
single Justice League character you've
ever seen your entire life he said the
flashpoint movie will explore new ground
just meaning that they're gonna change
the comic book story based on the
elements that they're working with like
they've established a set backstory for
all these characters they've interacted
with each other so that's gonna play
into the story of flashpoint naturally
everyone freaked out when he said that
name Batman why did you have to say that
name because that means that they might
be able to do thomas wayne he did not
confirm thomas wayne although Jeffery
Dean Moore
has been really quite I posted a video a
little while ago of him being kg of
Thomas Wayne Batman Bruce Wayne's father
and it looked a little bit like Javier
Bardem because you look almost identical
right here Bardem so you at that time
you didn't say yes you didn't say no but
now I've learned that if there's some
comic series where Thomas Wayne is a
Batman they look at Batman dad Batman or
something yeah are you going to paradox
universe Batman
flashpoint Batman in the flash movie
obviously he couldn't say anything no
matter what so it's not like he's gonna
say yeah I'm definitely in the
flashpoint movie he could just be really
funny about it and try and talk around
it gotta get that discretionary bonus
for keeping those secrets if you didn't
know actors are forced to keep things
secret but they get a bonus for doing
that so they don't give away spoilers
they get like an extra chunk of change
when the movie comes out and everybody
loves money so of course they keep their
mouth shut
but then there's gal coats wonder woman
there's cyborg there's Aquaman like
there's the whole storyline when Aquaman
and Wonder Woman are in that ship and
you have famous Kira at war with the
Atlanteans is this whole big thing that
has very little to do with the Flash's
singular story about him trying to save
his mother in his war with the
reverse-flash it's just all part of the
larger global conflict that he causes
because of the flashpoint timeline so
when we're talking about the actual
flashpoint movie you just have to be
realistic about the perspective that the
film is going to take obviously it's
mostly going to follow around
Ezra Miller's character and because of
the box-office performance of Justice
League I think they're going to not call
it Justice League flashpoint those just
call it something like flashpoint and
keep it really simple or they'll say the
flash flash point the other important
part of the conversation is is what are
they going to use flashpoint to change
in the DC extended universe how are they
going to reset character personalities
because they've kind of already done
that with Superman they reckoned him
just a little bit between Batman V
Superman and now a lot of you asked me
if it's going to be a straight-up reboot
of the DC Universe and then there's a
lot of confusion about the comic book
flashpoint storyline in what's changed
comes back like how he resets things
when he fixes it at the end of the story
the important thing to remember is is
they're not rebooting the DC movie
universe what they're doing is is
they'll just tune the character
personalities a little bit and that's
pretty much it the most major thing that
they could possibly do would be to
transition from Ben Affleck's Batman to
another version of the Batman but
honestly I think they'll just save that
for the Batman Matt Reeves movie I don't
think they would try to do something so
big with the Batman character in
somebody else's movie because it's a
flash movie and if they change to a
different version of the Batman at the
end of that that's all people would be
talking about it'd be all about this new
Batman coming into the universe and it's
really a story about the flash dealing
with grief in the death of his mother so
they want you to focus on that so that's
why I don't think they're gonna shoot or
knit any big Batman changes but when it
comes to the other Justice League
members honestly I think it'll be cameo
level so remember how much Aquaman we
got during Justice League that's
probably about the same amount of
Aquaman will get during the flashpoint
movie so like he'll get some really cool
stuff to do and we'll get to see an
alternate version of him because events
will have changed but because of how
controversial the CG has been during
Justice League I think they'll pull back
just a little bit and try to focus more
on the character work so I'm not
expecting them to do a war between the
Amazons and Atlantis they might tease
some fight between the Justice League
the way we got at the monument was
Superman just a slightly different
version of that Geoff Johns talked about
the Batman story of it all obviously
that's very important the Thomas Wayne
Batman but what about the Superman story
of it all during the comic book
storyline Superman's pod had been taken
by the government and as a baby he just
been kept underground so he never got
the full dose of sunlight so he's in
this weakened state
so flash and cyborg have to go break him
out we just got done watching a version
of the world dealing with the death of
Superman everything went to so
that's pretty much what it looks like
during flashpoint so I don't think
they're gonna do the exact same thing
two times in a row like remember that
time when everything was really shitty
Superman was dead if you thought he was
gone well we're gonna show you what it
looks like when he was never around it's
also super shitty so I'm expecting some
changes to the suit
man's storyline they'll probably slim
down the roster of characters quite a
bit and then obviously the biggest new
thing is reverse-flash we've gotten no
sign of him in the DC Universe yet
other than the plot twist a Barry's
father being falsely accused of his
mother's murder so that's just the Tia
for him finding out the reverse-flash is
really the person who came back to kill
his mother and I know you know in terms
of story I actually used some of that
Batman V Superman footage because it was
kind of their version of flashpoint that
they were already setting up him telling
Batman about Lois so they could prevent
the nightmare version of Superman from
coming to pass so because the DC
Universe has taken such a left turn in
the tone of everything I don't think
that they're gonna go back to that I
think originally that's what flashpoint
was going to look like but I think
they've changed their mind since then
it'll try to promote Superman as a more
hopeful figure so whatever his role is
is in flashpoint he's not gonna be an
evil version of himself because we kind
of already got a version of that at the
monument but as for right now there's no
release date because they haven't had
that director once they get the director
and they have their script the way they
want it then they'll announce the
release date but we have Aquaman coming
out December 21st next year Shazam
coming out April 5th 2019 tentatively
Zachary Levi was just cast as that
character we have Wonder Woman too which
is now set for November 1st 2019
there's the Batman movie obviously we
don't know when the release dates going
to be the cyborg movie is still on the
schedule Green Lantern Corps still on
the schedule
they're getting ready to cast the movie
version of Nightwing we'll probably find
out who that is in the next six months
Joss Whedon is still doing the Batgirl
movie there been some rumors about that
there may be another Justice League film
but if the film doesn't perform the way
they wanted to like in the next month or
so if it doesn't make the amount of
money that they want they'll probably
wait at least five to six years before
trying to do it again and you just see
characters popping up and helping out
every once in a while the way you saw
Iron Man
during spider-man homecoming like you
saw little tags during Wonder Woman so
it is connected to the other movies so
just expect the interconnectedness of
the universe to look like that going
forward there's a new brand of that
blast ring giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video congratulations to
the winner from the last video
Rhino Jordan please private message
so I can get your contact details you
can click here to learn about all the
big Justice League deleted scenes and
deleted storylines and click here for
the latest big flash crossover trailer
thank you so much for watching everybody
say awesome Happy Thanksgiving